hey everybody it's Mike from overflows I
hope you had a good weekend today is uh
Monday September 19th uh 2022 and today
I'll be talking about uh
Point controls right point of control in
the order flow is the price level in the
bar with the most volume it's simply uh
derived by looking at the volume traded
at the price
on the bid and the offer right every bar
has a point of control so
all you're really doing is to calculate
the point of control right is not just
you're looking at the volume that was
traded on the bid so for example 38 uh
55 and a half there's 449 on the bid 5
26 on the offer right you add that up
440 oops calculator 449 plus 526 gives
you 9.75 it's the most volume at any
price level in the bar you can see over
here it was just 83 contracts traded
um you know over here it was 166. so out
of the entire bar this was the price
level with the most volume and
it's important to understand where the
volume is trading in a bar now generally
most of the time
you know in a you know if if you've ever
studied statistics you know the the
normal distribution will tell you that
the most volume is going to trade sort
of in the middle of the bar more or less
not necessarily the exact middle but
somewhere towards the middle now this is
what gets interesting and the order flow
is it doesn't always turn out that way
right volume doesn't always
uh the majority of the volume doesn't
always appear in the middle of the bar
and where it gets kind of more
interesting is you some softwares will
do it for you
but I don't think it's really necessary
you can actually
put up
poc2 and poc3 poc2 would be this the
price level with this the second most
volume POC would be the price level with
the third most volume so let's just take
a look at this we'll just make it a
different color so it's not going to
confuse us with the regular
POC
um
is there yellow on here make kind of a
yellow one on gold
make that gold okay so I'm just going to
put up the normal PLC will be the
gray color box the second PLC will be
the blue color box and
the third POC will be the gold color box
just so you can give give you an idea of
how volume sometimes just really gets
distributed out in a bar right normal
way to think of it is you know volume
would be concentrated somewhere towards
the middle of the bar you know ideally
in a perfect world you have POC smack in
the middle second POC right above it
maybe the third POC right below it but
as we're going to see when you start
looking at the different pocs you know
where they appear in the bar
oftentimes it's distributed throughout
you know maybe early in the bar there
was some heavy volume at the bottom
then the market started moving and put
the volume again you know towards the
middle then finally you know as the
market started uh bar getting close to
closing the pocs at a different level so
you can see right on you know these
normal distribution bars if you will
want to control right here second PLC
third PLC now cash opens up right now
we're starting to get more volume and
you can see point of control
second point of control third point of
control
okay here you know they're all sort of
grouped together but here they're kind
of spread out here's point of control
kind of in the middle second point of
control above it third point of control
below it
all right group together group together
grouped together kind of just spread out
a little bit some spacing group together
grouped together
now this big gap between the point of
control and the second point of control
okay so you can see
how it's spread out right and oftentimes
okay you've seen some bars you know some
big gaps in between some of the point of
controls generally speaking you know
volume tends to concentrate
in a certain area in the bar why is
because you know people are happy to
sort of transact at these levels right
for example this red bar here right
point of controls
all sort of grouped together right
people are happy to transact here you
know the market is a bit offered you
know the trade's a thicker to above
comes back down trades you know at that
point of control so oftentimes when
Market starts moving
you know you're going to see big
changes in the points of control
from previous points of control
now you know that's just again that's
you know something for more advanced
Traders I don't want you guys thinking
you got to put up point of control two
and point of control three on your chart
you don't really need them unless you're
you know a point of control fanatic and
you're really into it but you know the
first point of control the main point of
control
the one
with the most volume is is what's going
to be
use the most in your analysis right
again once you start getting into you
know second point of controls third
point of controls it's nice to look at
but
unless you're more advanced in your
order flow analysis you know having more
of them up there sometimes people think
well I could put second and third point
of control on my chart I'm gonna put it
on there but at the end of the day it's
kind of useless because you're not
really using it and it's just giving you
oftentimes sort of conflicting signals
yeah you think you're seeing something
happening in the volume
and you know you're just putting more
pressure on yourself to have to make
decisions
um I said unless you're really focused
on point of controls and you're going to
concentrate on point of controls only
you know you can build a sort of a whole
strategy around it okay maybe you can
start looking at them but you need to do
your research but really what I want to
talk about today is the point of
controls and its relation to price in
the bar
and
I can't stress this enough right markets
rotate okay and it's important to
understand
is from one rotation you often get a
reversal into another rotation
so what I mean is okay so here's Cash
open okay 8 30 and Market start going up
right you're getting nice movements in
the points of control
you get up here you guys sort of got
this swing High okay right in here
point of control sort of again in the
middle of the bar we're closing you know
on the other side of point of control
right we're closing above the point of
control which is what you want to see on
a market that's going up look at these
bars here okay in general
as you're moving higher
right here here here pointed control or
sorry price is closing Beyond point of
control Beyond point of control Beyond
point of control right point of control
we're closing way up here there's point
of control we're closing one tick above
Point control is way down here we're
closing above you do get one or two bars
here where we're
closing just below point of control
closing below point of control again
we're closing above point of control
above point of control above point of
control that's what you like to see on a
nice moving market right is price moving
away from volume right I mean volume is
going higher obviously these points of
controls are going higher
price is also going higher okay and
where it gets interesting is where you
start to get up
at swing highs you got to start watching
for bars like this where we poke up
point of control
is above where price closed okay to me
that's a sign of markets kind of getting
a little bit weaker
okay then we close above
when a control close above point of
control
this is a green bar actually here we
close above point of control
I just have another indicator printing a
red signal on there
then you get up here okay what do you
got well you got two pointed controls
side by side
price is closing below point of control
that's not a good sign it's a sign of
weakness right
then obviously we're closing right at
the point of control red bars obviously
closing down below get the green bar we
close above Point control okay fine fair
enough then red red pointy controls
start moving down you get a bit start to
see that bit of a sell-off okay come
back up here right we're closing
look on this move up
price closes higher than the point of
control price closes higher than the
point of control price closes higher
than the point of control
now price closes below point of control
that's the sign of weakness
again Market starts to sell off a little
bit it does and then starts rallying
again
you gotta sign a weakness here again
right point of control is up here we
close below it
okay then we come right back close above
it sort of close right on it close
through it
this is also a green can you know I'd
only take this
let me just make a change here real
quick uh change this to one
because I just got something else
running over those candles
um that's why it looks red it's actually
green so you got this green candle
pointing control way up here we're
closing way down here it's not a good
sign
the next bar going to control sort of in
the middle it's a red candle so
obviously we're closing down
and we closed you know right near our
low of the bar but we're closing well
below that point of control so we're
putting it in higher volumes up here but
we're closing These Bars below it to me
that's a sign of weakness right and how
you want to be trading it is you're
going to trade in the direction
I hate to say trade in the direction of
weakness but
its weakness in the market going up
strengthen the market going down think
of it that way even though it's it you
know it's it's kind of misleading to say
it's Market weakness but what you have
is Market weakness on the move up that
move is weakening
so far you're not seeing strong strength
to the downside
I mean you're starting to see it in here
as price moves away from the volume but
then when you start looking at the
additional pieces of order flow that's
just the point of controls giving you a
hint that there's weakness in the market
now you're looking at the Delta oh I got
negative negative Delta you start you
know follow what I was telling you last
week as you're going higher see Delta is
strong then gets weaker then it gets
negative
okay well we're going up but Delta's
getting weak you know you sort of have
this Delta flip that I told you about
last week where it was very strong early
plus 621 it closed it just 77.
so it went from positive 621 back down
to 77 right again that's another sign of
weakness you're seeing signs of weakness
the way price reacts to where point of
control is so you've seen some signs of
weakness up here what's the trade it
trades to the downside right and you get
a nice move basically from you know the
85 and a half 86 area down into you know
the the 70s 76 77 in here
okay and then again similar thing
happens markets rallying here okay we
put in a rally closing on the point of
control
kind of a bearish point of control but
Mark came right back on the next one
again it's not that you just see a bar
like this where point of control is way
up here price is down here you get short
now you still gotta look at the
follow-through in the order flow
right it's not just oh here's my here's
my trade right here no watch what's
happening in the order flow
again Point control in the middle just
below it then closing right on the point
of control closing right on the point of
control finally we get all the way up
here we got this doji bar again doji
candles I tend not to lean one way or
the other on them as far as getting
longer getting short
um and we just keep going higher higher
higher we're making these new highs of
the day
and start coming off again rotating
around again I'm just looking at this
from the
let's say green candles section you know
I could probably do another video on on
the red candles but what you'd look for
there
um
this one is very it was very interesting
um you got the point of control right up
here near the top of the bar bar closed
basically on it you know one tick below
it then obviously the next candle Point
control way down
um you know giving you a nice potential
short opportunity but I just like the
when I'm looking at you know potential
swing highs like this right we just
rallied up from you know the 74 area all
the way up into the 84 area part of
control right up here but we're not
holding it right we're trading below
that point of control and then the next
bar opponent controls lower and we're
closing you know essentially on our low
of that bar right that's that's a
negative sign just you know here right
this is there your swing high again from
this move up you have this swing High
here
but we're above the point of control
okay so again I wouldn't be thinking of
potentially getting short you know I
mean if there's if I were to sort of
write down some instructions for you
it'd be like at a swing High
close below the point of control
and then in the next bar
you know close down
start moving lower
and close below that point of control
okay so you can see how the difference
of here and here is right we're above
the point of control to me there's still
a little bit more capacity for this move
to keep going whereas this one not so
much
okay so you know again you know that's
it from the green and red candle side
you know maybe later or tomorrow I'll
put one out um you know for the opposite
side what to look for but you can sort
of get the idea of what you should be
looking for
um you know with with point of controls
and where price closes relative relative
um to them okay so thanks for watching
this video
and be sure to like And subscribe the
channel
and you know again put some comments in
there my my plan is like once I start
getting enough comments I'm going to
make a video replying to your comments
so thanks everybody and have a great day